so I was coming home late a few nights
it was like just before Ramadan I was
doing like voluntary prayers in the
Masjid with like friends I was running a
little late so I was coming home later
and I was like man I don't know how I'm
gonna do this in Ramadan so I came home
and my family was just like waiting for
me and they're like are you coming home
so late every day and they thought I was
doing illegal stuff Spurt of the moment
I just said I converted to it I didn't
even know how to word it so I just had
to say it because serbians it's like a
really bad connection with this like
they don't really like it if you enjoyed
this short clip visit the D show TV on
YouTube to watch the full video